‘You all know exactly who I am.’
The bald chemistry teacher looked around at
the men surrounding him in the desert.
Cadillacs, leather jackets, blacked-out shades.
The gang members shifted nervously from foot
to foot as the man bragged openly about what
he’s done to build his criminal empire.
Walter White’s attention turned back to
the man in front of him, a slight sneer played
around his lips.
‘Now, say my name.’
The man took a moment to reply as the desert
wind blew behind him.
He seemed to be weighing his options, realizing
quickly that he had lost all control over
the situation.
‘Heisenberg.’
‘You’re g-’
BANG!
Walter White fell to the ground dead.
The characters all around yelped in surprise,
drew their guns, and started wildly pointing
them around the circle, trying to figure out
who killed the great Heisenberg.
But his killer just stared in awe from his
couch in the front room as the Netflix show
kept playing on the TV.
Had the toy gun in his hand really done that?
*
Josh had admitted to himself that he had a
problem a long time ago.
But at least being a yard-sale addict was
cheaper than just a regular old retail addict.
Actually in truth, he was also an estate-sale
addict, a garage-sale addict and a thrift
store addict.
Anywhere you could buy people’s old junk
for rock-bottom prices, he’d sniff it out.
The Saturday that his life changed forever
was just like any other Saturday, really.
In the sweaty heat of the Atlantic City suburbs,
he hadn’t meant to stop by any sales today,
but one just so happened to catch his eye.
There was a box marked ‘Nerd Stuff’ and
he took that as a personal challenge.
Was this some old lady’s version of nerd
stuff or a veteran Dungeon Master’s treasure
trove?
The reality was somewhere in-between the two.
There were a couple of seasons of Buffy on
VHS, a copy of the original Deus Ex, and some
Legend of Zelda plushies.
It hadn’t really been worth stopping his
car for, except for a little plastic splash
of color that caught his eye.
Josh reached way down to the bottom of the
box and rooted around for it.
There was no way, it couldn’t possibly be
the toy he’d spent all his childhood asking
for and never getting.
But it was!
A 1985 Nintendo Entertainment System Zapper!
With an orange grip and barrel, NES gray bodywork,
and the beautiful font printed along the side,
it was unmistakable.
He threw a wad of cash at the old lady behind
the table and rushed back into his car, quickly
as he could.
It was time to cancel his day plans, he had
a childhood dream to fulfill!
But no sooner than he had got home and flipped
on his TV, the dream came crashing down around
him.
His old NES, the one he’d had since he was
a little kid, had sadly keeled over.
It refused to power on, no matter what he
did.
So that made his Zapper pretty much useless.
The best he could do with it now would be
to point it at the TV and make pew pew noises
with his mouth.
So Josh opened up Netflix and put on an episode
of Breaking Bad.
Little did he know, as he raised the Zapper
to the screen, that he was actually in possession
of SCP-674.
Nobody would know looking at it on the surface,
even the most hardcore gamers wouldn’t have
a clue, because you can fully disassemble,
clean, and reassemble the Zapper and get no
indication that it’s anything other than
what it appears to be.
However, as soon as the gun is pointed at
a television screen or a computer monitor
of any kind, it starts to pose a very real
threat.
Or, at least, a very real fictional threat.
If you shoot at the screen, whatever media
is playing on it at the time will react and
adapt to what has just happened.
That means characters on the screens will
react in accordance with the rules of their
respective universes.
In a grounded, realistic drama, the gunshot
will behave like any other, killing or wounding
the victim with perhaps enough time for them
to give a dying monologue, but in an episode
of Rick and Morty, the shot could manifest
in any number of bizarre creative ways.
News crews that witness the user shooting
a person in their live report will continue
to cover the incident as if it is part of
the ongoing story.
If you shoot Walter White, he falls to the
ground dead.
Josh stared at the screen in utter amazement.
He didn’t expect the writers to kill off
their main character just like that.
Wasn’t there supposed to be another 9 episodes?
What would they do to fill all that time?
As the episode played out, it seemed to mostly
just follow Jesse, trying desperately to escape
with his money before it was too late.
He kept glancing towards the camera for some
reason, with a slight look of fear in his
eyes.
Very strange creative decision there.
Josh backed out of the show to scroll through
his “continue watching.”
There was something a little creepy about
how he’d pointed that Zapper at the TV,
pulled the trigger, and perfectly, at that
moment, a character had been shot.
Time to pick out a show without any guns and
murder for a bit.
Something safe.
The familiar melodica tune filled the lounge
as various shots of Dunder Mifflin employees
busied themselves, shredding credit cards
and answering phone calls.
It never ceased to make his worries go away
seeing the words ‘The Office’ appear on
the screen.
He settled into the couch, watching as the
characters all gathered in the conference
room for some first-aid training.
The CPR dummy lay on the floor with Michael
Scott earnestly explaining to the woman that
the victim appeared to have lost their limbs.
He laughed along as the scene descended into
chaos, as none of the employees took the training
seriously at all.
Even though he’d seen this episode countless
times, it never got old.
Absent-mindedly, he pointed the gun at the
TV and pulled the trigger.
BANG!
Pam collapsed on the ground.
All of the characters dived out of the way,
trying to find cover behind their chairs,
not daring to peek out at the camera.
Only the first aid lady stayed on the scene,
trying her best to resuscitate Pam.
It cut to a shot of Dwight talking to the
camera sadly.
He said something that was almost funny, but
there was a real heaviness in the moment.
His eyes were red, like he’d been crying
off-camera.
Josh flipped the TV off and stared at himself
in the dark reflection.
Was he dreaming?
He hadn’t just done that… had he?
Fortunately for Josh and for the rest of humanity,
he had not killed Jenna Fisher or Bryan Cranston.
He hadn’t even killed their characters in
the shows, at least not for anyone other than
himself.
Research into SCP-674 shows that the appearance
of characters being killed off on screen only
exists in the mind of the shooter.
For everyone else, The Office remains the
same as it always was.
Unfortunately for Josh, however, Pam is now
dead in that universe and will always be whenever
he watches an episode.
It leaves a real shadow over the later seasons,
but the characters apparently manage to do
a good job pivoting into its new darker tone.
Other shows that have been tested in research
conditions have yielded interesting results.
Like in Star Trek, it is impossible to actually
kill Captain Kirk.
Instead, various red shirts always just so
happen to dive in front of him or fall into
frame at the pivotal moment.
With a small dead zone on the right-hand side
of the screen, characters who witness enough
shootings have the sense to stick to that
side of the frame whenever the shot is on
them, sometimes going so far as to plead directly
with the viewer, breaking the fourth wall
in their desperation to survive.
When Josh came back from a long walk outside,
he’d convinced himself that what he had
seen earlier was all just some vivid dream.
A dream he didn’t remember waking up from
but definitely wasn’t happening anymore.
He’d play some video games, that’s what
he’d do.
He had decided he would just play some Super
Smash Bros and unwind.
Anyone who has ever said that sentence to
themselves will know firsthand how foolish
that is.
Not ten minutes later, Josh had definitely
forgotten all about his dream from before.
He was too busy raging and cursing at the
screen.
He couldn’t stand playing against King Dedede,
that stupid hammer move always got him.
Without thinking, Josh snatched the Zapper
from the couch next to him and blasted Dedede
right in the face.
In classic Smash Bros style, the giant penguin
king was launched backwards, flying off the
screen in a blast of colorful smoke.
But he didn’t respawn.
For a second, his character just stood on
the screen awkwardly before it kicked him
back out to the character select screen.
This time though, King Dedede’s picture
was missing.
Josh couldn’t help himself.
He set up a free for all match straight away,
picking all of the characters he hated to
fight against.
Sonic, Mario, Pikachu, Bowser, Link, Nes,
even Wii Fit Trainer.
One after the other.
Bang bang bang!
He felt a strange sense of satisfaction once
he’d done his work.
Great, now the character list only had the
fair, balanced ones left.
They just so happened to all be his favorite
characters too.
But why stop there?
Josh jumped across to Elden Ring and marched
his knight up through the gate to Stormveil
Castle.
Before Margit had even gotten through his
opening cutscene, Josh had shot the boss right
in the face.
This boss battle that he’d been stuck on
for hours was over before it even started.
What else could he do now?
He put on an episode of Stranger Things and
shot the Demogorgon, then Moff Gideon in the
Mandalorian, and some goblins in Hogwarts
Legacy.
The clickers from the Last of Us took a couple
of extra shots but went down easy enough.
He went over to his PC and killed the Ender
Dragon in Minecraft without blowing up any
beds.
He won a game of Rocket League 53-0 after
he shot both cars on the opposing team.
He played through DOORS in Roblox without
a single jumpscare.
He’d just shoot any monster that filled
his screen.
What could be better?
He reckoned it was time for more movies.
Walking back across the lounge, spinning the
gun around his finger like a Western, he wondered
if now would be a good chance to hunt down
all the legendary animals in Red Dead 2.
It would certainly make the job a lot easier
if he could kill them all in just one shot.
He’d just need to be careful not to shoot
Arthur by accident.
But then Josh sat on the remote.
The TV flicked over to an old rerun of Bob
Ross just as he’d been squaring up to shoot.
He pulled the trigger before he could react.
The canvas was spattered red.
From somewhere off-camera he heard the artist’s
wheezing voice try to comfort him.
‘There are no mistakes, just happy…’
But he died before he could say another word.
*
The Exposition Gun first came onto the SCP
Foundation’s radar when a strange police
report was doing the rounds on an email chain
amongst local authorities.
They were all finding a great deal of value
from a man called Josh, who had turned himself
in at his local station in Atlantic City for
‘killing like everyone’.
Naturally, the police took his report very
seriously, for all of about 10 minutes.
As soon as they realized that he was talking
about video games, TV, and movie characters,
the whole case turned into one big joke.
They sat Josh down in front of a TV and played
him episodes of the shows he was talking about,
pointing out characters still alive in scenes
after he’d supposedly shot them to death,
but he seemed to just grow more distressed
as he realized he was experiencing this phenomenon
alone.
By the time, Foundation agents tracked Josh
down and took him in for questioning, the
gun had moved on.
He’d marched it straight back to the old
lady who’d sold it to him, who had then
sold it on again.
Josh’s full account of events and description
of the Zapper were taken before he was administered
Class C amnestics and allowed to continue
with his yard-sale addiction uninhibited.
SCP-674 was found some time later in the possession
of a 33-year-old Caucasian male simply referred
to as Mr S. A reclusive man in a neighboring
city, Mr S first gained the SCP Foundation's
attention through his extremist political
blog, in which he claimed to have assassinated
prominent political figures, news anchors,
and talk show hosts.
While the truth of those claims was demonstrably
false, it was clear from the way he described
events that he really did believe the delusion.
After being questioned, it was discovered
that he had never left his home.
Instead, he stayed on his couch, watching
news reports and firing at any prominent figures
that appeared, believing that he was indeed
killing them in the real world.
Despite claiming that he was using SCP-674
to prevent a military police state, using
the device to "assassinate" so many high-profile
figures had the opposite effect on his video
reality.
In his blog posts, he described an increasingly
unstable global order, martial law, and catastrophic
events consistent with the hypothetical release
of two deadly SCPs.
His house was barricaded, with security cameras
set up in every direction.
The more he had been using the gun, the more
the characters and journalists on TV had threatened
him, claiming that the SCP Foundation were
on their way to apprehend him and that he
would face retribution for what he had been
doing.
Mr S’s intended ambush of Foundation agents
failed.
While they appeared to be dying on the security
feeds he had set up, the agents experienced
no physical harm in reality as they apprehended
the man and seized SCP-674.
While the majority of researchers have deemed
that SCP-674 is harmless to all but the mental
well-being of the shooter, there was a notably
sinister result to Mr S’s time in Foundation
detention.
Alone in his cell, Mr S soon started to engage
in heated arguments with the security camera
set up to monitor him.
There is no record of any voices in the room
other than his own, yet he seemed to be locked
in a fierce argument.
All of a sudden, Mr S dropped to the ground
dead with three .38 caliber handgun bullets
lodged in his chest.
The entirety of his holding cell was searched
for evidence of a shooter, but none was found.
The Exposition Gun remains in a locked plastic
case in Storage Site 23.
Aside from regular cleaning and maintenance,
it is used under controlled circumstances
to creatively gather intelligence about further
SCP activity.
In the event of the site being compromised,
personnel are allowed to destroy the Exposition
Gun at their own discretion, should it fall
into the wrong hands.
Now check out “SCP-348 - A Gift from Dad”
and “SCP-978 - Desire Camera” for more!